so we're just going to show the cold
open well you do this
your shoulder's gotten gripped soft
clapped and slapped for 15 months right
that's it heal you're still getting all
of this right
[Music]
hey conan o'brien here uh for another
edition of behind the nonsense this is
where we explore some of the tomfoolery
behind the scenes how things got made
and uh we discuss very loosely uh how it
all happened with the people
who made it happen and i'm sitting here
with two terrific writers jesse gaskell
hey jesse hey conan jose arroyo hey
kenneth and um you seemed uncomfortable
looking all right
saying hey conan okay i love to try and
make him make it again i know we're
gonna stick with that i love that acorn
uh anyway i don't mean to embarrass you
but you're excellent writers and you
have come with me on every single travel
show whenever we go anywhere in the
world for conan without borders this is
a core of my writing team along with mr
mike sweeney we're going to talk now
about the cold open
for
the mexico show yes we went to mexico
city and we did a show and just to set
the table donald trump was elected
president in 2016. uh he said he was
going to build a wall and mexico would
pay for it stirred up i think a lot of
xenophobia
about mexico and the border and so this
is 2017
and we decided we should go to mexico
city and do a show and do it with the
help of the mexican people who work in
the television industry so this was the
cold open to
that show why don't we show it then
we'll talk about it and the show in
general let's take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
conan o'brien
i'm him
the communion
tv host
doing a big show in
check it out
americans are subject to extreme vetting
extreme vetting you might just be one of
those bad hombres
look i see what you're doing all right
we got some new people running in the
united states and that's created some
tension between our countries but you
can't lump all americans into one group
that's not fair
stereotyping
[Applause]
gracias thank you so much
that's just my easy time
okay
[Applause]
i wasn't sure if you guys would have
good mexican food
i stayed there like 15 years ago
okay and i stole the
towel what is yours to keep and i'll
just see myself
through the border this is a great great
gate
okay i don't know if you can see all the
way to the end but um i don't know if
that's the take where the dog actually
got me is that the take yes well that's
what we were just reminiscing finally
about i was told i think to get down
before the dog gets me but i always like
to go for it and um pretty sure that dog
chomped me on the thigh yeah well that
was a real police dog i mean that's a
like a belgian malinois is that the i
don't know i didn't hire the dog
i would have assumed you would have
gotten a non-lethal dog
but you're looking to me for like that
was the lethal dog that we got right
that's you who got the dog they were uh
they were trained and you were supposed
to run the dog was going to chase you
and you were supposed to stop at a
certain point but the i think well when
a killing dog is chasing you
hard to stop
uh as it nears
but and it broke the skin yeah yeah it
did break the skin uh and i remembered
walking back and it tore the pants leg
um and so i saw blood and and torn pants
leg and i thought uh we had other pants
so yeah what did you care about yeah for
us that's political about as political
as we get because we don't often do
political humor but it was such a
charged atmosphere and actually
something we like to do with a lot of
the kona without border shows is flip
the script so that
i'm
the american
in this case like the gringo is the
interloper so the power position's been
switched and so i thought it was a
really good idea that you guys had that
i'm trying to get into mexico and
they're harassing me the way people
thought we were harassing uh mexicans
who were trying to come and so
there was a real nice simplicity to it
but then we go to silly jokes that make
fun of me and the joke really is all the
way through on me which which is the
kind of stuff i like to do exactly
exactly and you took advantage of that
charged atmosphere
you know from the politics at the time
so all we had to do was you know give
the the same lines that trump was saying
to the mexican guards they're not
sending us their best or things like
that and of course it got a great
reaction yeah we shot it at televisa
in uh ciudad de mexico and everyone who
worked on it was
fantastic yes i mean they they helped us
it was important to me that we got to do
it with the help
of uh
mexican uh television makers and
executives and camera operators and
so um that was fun to show that cold
open to that audience they got a huge
kick out of it yeah and then they
watched me do a monologue
in spanish um and uh i remembered you
backstage you running because you're
fluent yes you just running it with me
over and over and over again so that my
my my accent was better my pronunciation
was a little more affluent because i
really wanted to earn the laughs that's
right in uh in spanish and so that ended
up working out buenas noches me llamo
conan o'brien see
oh oh como mekonos in
you did four or five monologue jokes the
same stuff that you do on you know in
the in the us show
and uh your phonetic pronunciation was
great it came out really good you know i
also think there's something that's
happened i noticed it with this piece
which is
we were really able to take advantage of
this
when we moved to los angeles we did all
those years in new york and
um made all this comedy that i'm that
i'm really proud of uh not all of it but
a lot of it
um
let's be honest it's a numbers game uh
but when we came here to los angeles and
the locations that we can get are so
cinematic and that was one of the things
that i counted on when we came out here
i didn't even know
that drones were going to be a thing but
the drone shots that we can get and so
it's that breaking bad look and we have
excellent camera technicians and and
cameramen and and people who know how to
make things look amazing they can always
match these looks and you guys were
always meticulous storyboarding things
and so to pull people into the reality
of a situation like that
you really do feel like i'm walking
across the desert and you're looking at
a legitimate piece of filmmaking rather
than the cold open to uh you know a
a nightly show so
that i think was
something that i was proud of i i do
feel bad about rubbing ham on the back
of your pants
you told me it was your uh good luck
ritual yeah and uh
you always have ham yes jose really does
have little leather pouches he'll wait
until we're sitting in traffic on a bus
or something and then he'll on a travel
show very obviously pull one out of his
backpack because he's it's almost like
the red flags
to see these tiny little things that i
saw he has he has a very eurocentric
sensibility and he has lots of little
tiny pouches and leather cases and he
has fine little pens and pencils and he
has little sketching pads and you've
never seen anything like them before
unless you were raised in holland and
he'll pull out this little pouch and
he'll open it up and there's one little
nectarine wedge that he keeps in there
and then he'll go like
and then like um just enough just enough
not too much
just enough and then you'll zip it up
again and uh i always wanted to throw
you out the bus window and i think
several times i did
[Music]
have this sold on ebay please absolutely
that's my saliva
hello oh spielberg excuse me